vous évoquez son avocat il n'est pas
venu ce matin maître liénard mais il a
répondu en question et de quentin calme
et je vous propose d'écouter sa première
réaction c'est une exclusivité pour
phoenix et l'un moi j'ai trouvé comme
subhanallah avait été convaincant parce
qu'il a donné l'ensemble des
explications possibles après si on
refuse obstinément de croire la vérité
eh bien eh bien on ne la croira jamais
mais ça n'en reste pas moins la vérité
la vérité c'est que monsieur benalla il
avait les fonctions qu'il a décrites ce
matin et vous ne trouverez personne pour
contester sa au sein de l'elysée
alors évidemment il y aura toujours des
gens qui fantasment euros qui diront que
cet état cowboys que c'était morambeau
que c'était un agent secret c'était pas
un agent secret c'était pas rambo cie ce
matin
l'audition s'est passée dans ces
conditions là c'est parce que justement
nous avions pris une position qui était
une position de fermeté et cela a permis
à tout le monde
d'un côté comme de l'autre de réfléchir
et de faire en sorte que la commission
soit sereine ce matin si nous n'avions
pas eu cette discussion et c'est cette
position de fermeté je pense que les
débats auraient été beaucoup moins
serein